monsters are they real  how does one come to know the C's dark  secrets  you seek resolutions  because you're young but you will  understand this one day  prepare  so much  you're psychotic  we've been gone too long  friends Hamlet  everything comes full circle  I'm just a man  civil liberties are being trampled on  their city people living in fear yeah  about a community that's right fine  they're in the hospital realize  something  to change a great many people see you as  a hero there are some would prefer the  word vigilante what have you done you've  operated with unlimited power and no  supervision together captain you seem a  little defensive  boss been a long day  [Music]  and samuel arrest me this nonetheless  you know I wouldn't do this fight any  other choice  right  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]